HUTCHINSON, IN MOMENTS.
HELLO, I'M JAKE TAPPER IN
WASHINGTON WHERE THE STATE OF
OUR UNION IS HAVING COLD WAR
FLASHBACKS.
THE U.S. IS ENTERING A SERIES OF
URGENT MEETINGS WITH RUSSIA THIS
WEEK, AT ONE OF THE MOST
PRECARIOUS MOMENTS WITH THAT
NATION, SINCE THE FALL OF THE
SOVIET UNION.
ON MONDAY, U.S. OFFICIAL ALSO
MEET WITH THEIR RUSSIAN
COUNTERPARTS IN GENEVA IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DEESCALATE THE CRISIS
WITH UKRAINE WHICH RUSSIA SEEMS
POISED TO INVADE, WITH THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY MOBILIZE
TWICE THAT MANY, FOLLOWING THE
BILATERAL MEETINGS IN GENEVA,
REPRESENTATIVES FROM NATO WILL
MEET WITH THE RUSSIAN DELEGATION
IN BRUSSELS.
THE STAKES OF THESE MEETINGS ARE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
THE U.S. IS WARNING OF STEEP
SANCTIONS IF RUSSIA MOVES
FORWARD TO INVADE AND THERE ARE
ALREADY CONCERNS THE RUSSIANS
ARE NOT REMOTELY ENTERING THE
NEGOTIATIONS IN GOOD FAITH.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS IS
SECRETARY OF STATE ANTONY
BLINKEN.
SECRETARY BLINKEN, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
LET'S START ON THE TALKS
BEGINNING TOMORROW HE KNOW VA.
PRESIDENT PUTIN RULING OUT
EXPANDING NATO TO INCLUDE
UKRAINE, ARE EITHER OF THOSE ON
THE NEGOTIATING TABLE?
>> NEITHER OF THOSE IS ON THE
ABLE, JAKE, BUT HERE'S WHERE WE
ARE.
THERE ARE TWO PATHS BEFORE US.
THERE'S A PATH OF DIALOGUE AND
DIPLOMACY TO TRY TO RESOLVE SOME
OF THESE DIFFERENCES, AND AVOID
A CONFRONTATION.
THE OTHER PATH IS CONFRONTATION
AND MASSIVE KCONSEQUENCES FOR
RUSSIA IF IT INCREASES ITS
PRESSURE ON UKRAINE.
WE HAVE IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN US STARTING TOMORROW AS
WELL AS AT NATO, AS WELL AS AT
THE ORGANIZATION FOR SECURITY
AND COOPERATION IN EUROPE.
WE'RE GOING TO LISTEN TO
RUSSIA'S CONCERNS, THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO LISTEN TO OUR
CONCERNS.
IF THEY ARE PROCEEDING IN GOOD
FAITH, WE THINK WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING CONCERNS
ON BOTH SIDES THAT WOULD REDUCE
TENSIONS AND DEAL WITH IMPROVING
SECURITY.
WE'LL DO THAT IN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH EUROPEAN
ALLIES AND PARTNERS.
WE MADE CLEAR TO RUSSIA THERE'S
NOTHING ABOUT EUROPE WITHOUT
EUROPE, BUT ULTIMATELY, THIS IS
UP TO PRESIDENT PUTIN TO DECIDE
WHICH PATH HE'S GOING TO FOLLOW.
>> IT SEEMS UNLIKELY PUTIN WILL
WITHDRAW TROOPS OR TAKE AT LEAST
SOME OF THEM OFF THE BORDER
WITHOUT SOME CONCESSIONS BY THE
U.S.
YOU'VE ALREADY SAID THAT THOSE
TWO THAT I MENTIONED UP TOP ARE
OFF THE TABLE OR NOT ON THE
TABLE.
WHAT ABOUT MOVING, HAVING U.S.
WEAPONRY OUT OF POLAND, MOVING
IT FURTHER WEST OR MOVING
MISSILES?
WHAT ABOUT LIMITING THE SCOPE OF
U.S. MILITARY EXERCISE?
ARE ANY OF THOSE ON THE TABLE?
>> FIRST, JAKE, I DON'T THINK
WE'LL SEE ANY BREAKTHROUGHS IN
THE COMING WEEK.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO PUT
THINGS ON THE TABLE.
THE RUSSIANS WILL DO THE SAME.
BOTH DIRECTLY WITH US AT NATO AT
THE OSCE AND WE'LL SEE IF THERE
ARE GROUNDS FOR MOVING FORWARD.
HERE'S WHAT I CAN SAY.
FIRST, ANY PROGRESS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE IS GOING TO HAVE
TO HAPPEN ON A RECIPROCAL BASIS,
BY WHICH I MEAN IF THE UNITED
STATES AND EUROPE ARE TAKING
STEPS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
RUSSIA'S CONCERNS, RUSSIA WILL
HAVE TO DO THE SAME THING.
SECOND, NOTHING'S HAPPENING
WITHOUT EUROPE, AND THIRD, IT'S
HARD TO SEE MAKING ACTUAL
PROGRESS AS OPPOSED TO TALKING
IN AND ATMOSPHERE OF ESCALATION
WITH A GUN TO UKRAINE'S HEAD.
SO IF WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
MAKE PROGRESS, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SEE DEESCALATION, RUSSIA
PULLING BACK FROM THE THREAT
THAT IT CURRENTLY POSES TO
UKRAINE.
>> YOU DIDN'T RULE ANY OF THOSE
OUT.
THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH THE TABLE AS
THE EARLIER ITEMS WERE.
LET ME ASK YOU, GOING FORWARD,
IF THOSE CONCESSIONS ARE A
POSSIBILITY, YOU MUST --
POSSIBILITIES, YOU MUST BE
WORRIED ABOUT CREATING A
PRECEDENT IN WHICH PUTIN AT ANY
MOMENT CAN THROW 100,000 TROOPS
ON A BORDER AND THREAT ON IT
INVADE A COUNTRY UNTIL THE U.S.
GIVES HIM SOME OF WHAT HE WANTS,
THE SCENARIO YOU REFERRED TO
WHEN YOU SAID RUSSIA HAD A GUN
TO UKRAINE'S HEAD.
>> EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE, JAKE.
FIRST OF ALL, WHY ARE WE HERE?
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE REPEATEDLY
OVER THE LAST DECADE, RUSSIA'S
COMMITTED ACTS OF AGGRESSION
AGAINST NEIGHBORS, GEORGIA,
MOLDOVA, UKRAINE IN 2014 AND THE
RENEWED THREAT ABOUT UKRAINE
TODAY.
SECOND, THERE ARE LARGE
PRINCIPLES AT STAKE THAT GO TO
THE FUNDAMENTALS OF
INTERNATIONAL PEACE AND
SECURITY.
THE PRINCIPLE THAT ONE COUNTRY
CAN'T CHANGE THE BORDERS OF
ANOTHER BY FORCE.
THE PRINCIPLE THAT ONE COUNTRY
CAN'T DICTATE TO ANOTHER ITS
FOREIGN POLICY AND THE CHOICES
INCLUDING WITH WHOM IT WILL
ASSOCIATE, THE PRINCIPLE THAT
ONE COUNTRY CAN'T EXERT A SPHERE
OF INFLUENCE TO SUBJUGATE ITS
NEIGHBORS.
ALL OF THAT IS ON THE TABLE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY NOT ONLY ARE
WE STANDING UP BUT WE RALLIED
COUNTRIES NOT JUST IN EUROPE BUT
INDEED BEYOND TO MAKE IT CLEAR
TO RUSSIA THAT THIS AGGRESSION
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTED, WILL NOT
BE TOLERATED, WILL NOT STAND.
SO THE CHOICE IS RUSSIA.
IT'S ALSO NOT ABOUT MAKING
CONCESSIONS.
IT'S ABOUT SEEING WHETHER IN THE
CONTEXT OF DIALOGUE AND
DIPLOMACY WILL ARE THINGS THAT
BOTH SIDES, ALL SIDES CAN DO TO
REDUCE TENSIONS.
WE'VE DONE THAT IN THE PAST.
WE DID IT WITH THE INTERMEDIATE
NUCLEAR FORCES TREATY THAT
UNFORTUNATELY RUSSIA HAS
VIOLATED IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION PULLED OUT OF, IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE CONVENTIONAL
FORCES IN EUROPE, HAVING
TRANSPARENCY AND OTHER MEASURES
PUT IN PLACE ON THE WAY
EXERCISES TAKE PLACE AND THOSE
ARE CERTAINLY THINGS THAT CAN BE
REVISITED IF RUSSIA IS SERIOUS
ABOUT DOING IT.
>> YOU SAY THE U.S. WILL RESPOND
WITH MASSIVE CONSEQUENCES TO ANY
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION IN UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS RULED OUT
U.S. UNILATERAL TROOPS ON THE
GROUND.
WHAT SANCTIONS IS THE U.S.
WILLING TO IMPOSE AND ARE U.S.
TROOPS AS PART OF A NATO OR
INTERNATIONAL FORCE ON THE
TABLE?
>> WELL FIRST, WHEN IT COMES TO
CONSEQUENCES, IT'S NOT JUST US
WHO HAS BEEN SAYING THIS.
THE G7, THE LEADING DEMOCRATIC
ECONOMIES OF THE WORLD MADE
CLEAR THERE WOULD BE MASSIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR RENEWED RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION.
SO HAS THE EUROPEAN UNION AND
NATO AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ALL COUNTRIES IN
RECENT WEEKS TO ELABORATE THOSE,
TO COME TO AGREEMENT ON THE
STEPS WE'D TAKE TOGETHER IN THE
EVENT OF RENEWED RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION, INCLUDING THINGS
THAT WE'VE NOT DONE IN THE PAST
IN THE FACE OF PREVIOUS RUSSIAN
AGGR
AGGRESSION, ECONOMIC, FINANCIAL,
OTHER MEASURES.
I'LL NOT TELEGRAPH THE DETAILS
BUT I THINK RUSSIA HAS A PRETTY
GOOD IDEA OF THE KINDS OF THINGS
IT WOULD FACE IF IT RENEWS
AGGRESSION.
SECOND, WE'VE MADE CLEAR THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE AND
SUPPLY UKRAINE WITH THE
DEFENSIVE MILITARY EQUIPMENT TO
BE ABLE TO DEFEND ITSELF AND
IT'S ALSO CLEAR THAT IN THE
EVENT OF FURTHER RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION, NATO IS GOING TO
HAVE TO FURTHER REINFORCE ITS
EASTERN FLANK.
YOU KNOW, JAKE, WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT ALL OF THIS IS
PRESIDENT PUTIN TALKS ABOUT LOTS
OF THINGS HE'S CONCERNED ABOUT
AND THE VERY ACTIONS HE'S TAKEN
HAVE PRECIPITATED MUCH OF WHAT
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO PREVENT.
BACK IN 2014 BEFORE RUSSIA
INVADED UKRAINE, 25% OF
UKRAINIANS SUPPORTED UKRAINE
JOINING NATO.
NOW IT'S ABOUT 60%.
>> RIGHT.
>> SIMILARLY AFTER 2014, NATO
FELT COMPELLED BECAUSE OF
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION TO PUT MORE
FORCES AND MORE EQUIPMENT ON ITS
EASTERN FLANK CLOSER TO RUSSIA.
IT'S PRESIDENT PUTIN'S ACTIONS
THAT ARE PRECIPITATING WHAT HE
SAYS HE DOESN'T WANT.
>> YES.
>> THERE'S NOW AN OPPORTUNITY IF
HE TAKES IT THROUGH DIALOGUE,
THROUGH DIPLOMACY TO SEE IF WE
CAN ADDRESS ANY LEGITIMATE
RUSSIAN CONCERNS AS WELL AS
ADDRESS MANY CONCERNS THAT THE
UNITED STATES AND EUROPE HAVE
OVER RUSSIA'S CONDUCT.
>> RIGHT, BEYOND THIS MILITARY
BUILDUP ON THE UKRAINE BORDER,
RUSSIAN-LED TROOPS ARE
INTERVENING IN VIOLENT PROTESTS
IN KAZHAKSTAN AND STEPPED DOWN
IN THE BELARUS ELECTIONS.
FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY LEANNE
PANETTA SAID YEARS AGO HE
BELIEVES WHAT DRIVES PUTIN IS A
TE SIRE TO RESTORE THE OLD
SOVIET UNION.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF PRESIDENT
PUTIN'S OBJECTIVES TO REINSERT
HIS SPHERE OF INFLUENCE OVER
COUNTRIES THAT PREVIOUSLY WERE
PART OF THE SOVIET UNION.
AS WE SAID THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
WE CAN'T GO BACK TO A WORLD OF
INFLUENCE.
THAT WAS A RECIPE FOR
INSTABILITY, A RECIPE FOR
CONFLICT, A RECIPE THAT LED TO
WORLD WARS.
>> DO YOU THINK THE INVASION IS
LIKELY?
DO YOU THINK AN INVASION OF
UKRAINE IS LIKELY?
>> LOOK, I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHETHER IT'S LIKELY OR NOT.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DIALOGUE AND
DIPLOMACY TO SEE IF WE CAN
RESOLVE THESE CHALLENGES
PEACEFULLY.
THAT IS BY FAR THE PREFERABLE
COURSE.
IT'S BY FAR THE MOST RESPONSIBLE
COURSE, BUT EQUALLY, WE'RE
PREPARED TO DEAL VERY RESOLUTELY
WITH RUSSIA IF IT CHOOSES
CONFRONTATION, IF IT CHOOSE AS
DEPRESSION.
WE'LL SEE.
IT'S UP TO PRESIDENT PUTIN WHICH
PATH HE WANTS TO FOLLOW.
WE'RE PREPARED STARTING THIS
WEEK TO TALK THROUGH ALL OF THIS
AND HEAR THEIR CONCERNS AND THEM
TO HEAR OURS TO SEE IF WE CAN
MAKE PROGRESS.
>> KAZHAKSTAN'S PRESIDENT TO
"KILL WITHOUT WARNING"
PROTESTERS IN THE STREET.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IN OCTOBER
YOUR ADMINISTRATION "PUT HUMAN
RIGHTS BACK AT THE CENTER OF OUR
FOREIGN POLICY" AND "NO U.S.
PRESIDENT SHOULD STAND BY WHEN
HUMAN RIGHTS ARE UNDER ATTACK."
THEY'RE UNDER ATTACK IN
KAZHAKSTAN, AT LEAST 164 PEOPLE
WERE KILLED DURING PROTESTS THIS
WEEK.
>> I CONDEMNED THAT STATEMENT
AND IF THAT'S AN ACTUAL POLICY,
CONDEMN THAT POLICY, THE SHOOT
TO KILL.
I SPOKE TO MY COUNTERPART IN
KAZHAKSTAN A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
THE AUTHORITIES IN KAZHAKSTAN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FACING
PEACEFULLY TO MAKE SURE THE
RIGHTS OF THOSE PROTESTING
PEACEFULLY ARE PROTECTED, TO
PROTECT THE INSTITUTIONS OF THE
STATE AND LAW AND ORDER BUT TO
DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS RIGHTS
RESPECTING.
WE HAVE REAL QUESTIONS WHY THEY
FELT COMPELLED COULD CALL IN
THIS ORGANIZATION THAT RUSSIA
DOMINATES.
WE'RE ASKING FOR CLARIFICATION
ON THAT, BUT WHAT'S IMPERATIVE